in questa mia conferenza vorrei parlarvi
di un fenomeno abbastanza serio e
importante che fenomeno del randagismo
canino in sardegna
prima di tutto è opportuno fare un
analisi del problema il randagismo
alimentato per il 50 per cento dei cani
rurali ovvero dai cani dei pastori e dei
cacciatori che puntualmente ogni sei
mesi fanno figliare i propri cani e che
abbandonano i propri cani una volta che
hanno terminato il loro ciclo lavorativo
l'altro 50 per cento del randagismo è
alimentato dalle mancate sterilizzazioni
la sterilizzazione una pratica molto
diffusa nel nord italia mentre invece
incontra notevoli difficoltà al sud sia
per una questione culturale sia per una
questione economica
la sterilizzazione è il punto cardine
della lotta al randagismo sarebbe anche
opportuno parlare delle calde scusate ma
è un problema che mi vede coinvolta
personalmente per cui ho qualche
difficoltà a parlarne in maniera pacata
ci sono molti problemi legati al
randagismo uno dei quali è l'incolumità
pubblica infatti molti incidenti
stradali vengono causati a causa dei
cani vaganti il randagismo costituisce
anche un problema sanitario in quanto
molte malattie vengono trasmesse dai
cani vaganti dai cani randagi
soprattutto esiste in sardegna una
malattia che si chiama echinococco xi
che viene trasmessa dai cani provenienti
dagli umili il randagismo è un grosso
problema economico anche in quanto le
spese legate al randagismo
essendo un problema sempre più diffuso
sono sempre in aumento e sono sono
costantemente a carico dei comuni e
delle ausl non ultimo è un problema
etico
infatti questo fenomeno
non fa altro che darci dare un'immagine
negativa del cane stesso causando in
questo modo diciamo degli atti di
maltrattamento e di crudeltà nei
confronti dei cani randagi come viene
gestito in questo momento il randagismo
allora la responsabilità di cani dei
cani randagi e dei comuni e delle asl
in realtà il problema è gestito in
maniera abbastanza
come dire emergenziale nel senso che non
esistono veri e propri progetti che
possono guardare ad un futuro in cui non
ci saranno più cani randagi
il problema è gestito costantemente sul
giorno per giorno la maggior parte
comunque del dl e diciamo che i comuni l
ausl affidano quasi esclusivamente la
soluzione di questo problema e canili
privati
cosa possiamo fare in tutto questo
allora noi cerchiamo di proporre un
modello alternativo tutto ciò allora noi
siamo una cooperativa sociale di tipo b
abbiamo circa una decina di soci abbiamo
però una rete di volontari di circa 50
volontari che operano sul territorio ci
distinguiamo noi come tante altre
associazioni che nascono spontanee nel
territorio perché abbiamo la passione
per gli animali perché pensiamo di fare
questo tipo di attività spinti comunque
da dall amore per i cani
allora vorrei spiegarvi la differenza
tra l'arrivo di un cane in un canile
privato e non ha in un rifugio gestito
da volontari
allora in un canile privato il cane
arriva dietro segnalazione del comune o
della sla arriva con la calabria cani
significa che si fa di tutto per
catturarlo nel territorio
con metodi anche un po coercitivi dopo
di che arriva in un canile in questo
canile viene messo in quarantena
ciò significa che vedrà un operaio una
volta al giorno che di pulire al box che
gli darà da mangiare e basta questa è la
sua vita fino a che qualcuno forse forse
non andrà ad adottarlo
l'adozione di un cane in un canile
privato è un'operazione abbastanza
semplice perché basta presentarsi in un
canile privato avere un documento
d'identità e ci si portelli al cane
nessuno fa i controlli pre adozione e
nessuno fa i controlli post adozione
quando noi associazioni di volontariato
che operiamo nel territorio invece ci
occupiamo di un cane randagio in genere
rispondiamo quasi sempre una richiesta
d'aiuto o comunque uno dei nostri
volontari ha individuato il il cane
andiamo a cercarselo in pratica andiamo
a cercarlo nei territori organizziamo
una rete di volontari e ci prendiamo il
cane cercando di fargli meno male
possibile ovviamente nel migliore dei
modi il cane in questo modo viene
portato dal veterinario viene valutato
il suo stato fisico non sempre quasi
sempre i cani che troviamo sono affetti
dalle smaniosi vi ricordo che la
leishmaniosi è una malattia endemica che
in sardegna colpisce otto cani su dieci
mediamente dopo di che insomma le
analisi prestate le prime cure il cane
viene trasferito in un rifugio oppure in
stallo presso un'abitazione di uno dei
volontari
dopo di che cosa succede allora il cane
viene recuperato sia dal punto di vista
fisico sia dal punto di vista
psicologico
quasi sempre questi cani che vengono
recuperati hanno delle fobie
sono stati maltrattati insomma
presentano delle serie difficoltà a
trovare una famiglia
una volta recuperato il cane tutti i
volontari si prestano per potermi
trovare una casa
ciò significa che gli si deve trovare la
casa più adatta a lui
perciò prima di consegnare il cane ad
una famiglia vengono fatti tutti i
controlli pre affido e successivamente
una volta cons portato il cane presso la
famiglia perché noi lo portiamo presso
la casa in cui dopo andrà a vivere
dopodiché verranno fatti tutti i
controlli post affido così si conclude
l'adozione che è nettamente diversa da
quella che si verifica presso un canile
privato il canile privato in genere
prende per ogni cane che accoglie presso
le proprie strutture una media di 3 euro
3 euro e 60 giorno i volontari che
accolgono i cani presso i propri rifugi
non percepiscono nulla
questo cosa significa significa che il
50 per cento di questo fenomeno si è a
carico dei comuni e delle ausl l'altro
50 per cento è a carico dei volontari o
comunque delle persone di buona volontà
in tutto questo
questa serie di problemi
noi vorremmo porre fare una proposta
pensiamo di poter avere una soluzione
alternativa a quelli che sono gli
standard attuali
pensiamo che la soluzione al problema
del randagismo debba essere organizzato
in una serie di azioni utili a
non sa gestire il fenomeno come
attualmente viene fatto ma a risolverlo
la prima azione da compiere è quella di
organizzare delle campagne di
sterilizzazione al tappeto a parte i
cani che devono essere sterilizzati nei
canini
sarebbe opportuno che le ausl
provvedessero alla sterilizzazione
gratuita dei cani ospiti dei rifugi
privati per esempio oppure provvedesse
alla sterilizzazione dei cani che di
proprietà delle famiglie disagiate per
esempio un altra soluzione sarebbe
quella di sterilizzare obbligatoriamente
i cani dei cacciatori e dei pastori
anzi sarebbe anche opportuno che venga
definito un numero massimo di cani
detenuti sia da pastori che da
cacciatori altra soluzione da applicarsi
sempre contemporaneamente a tutte le
altre sarebbe indispensabile svolgere
delle campagne di microcippatura
gratuita per tutti i cittadini presso
ogni comune
un'altra cosa da fare sarebbe dare degli
incentivi a coloro che adottano un cane
ma non solo
attualmente vengono dati degli incentivi
a chi adotta un cane da un canile
privato o da un canile comunale
in realtà sarebbe opportuno anche dare
degli incentivi a coloro che adottano un
cane anche dai rifugi o comunque dei
volontari che operano sul territorio
altri
vita potrebbero essere l'inserimento
nelle scuole della educazione cinofila
obbligatoria in questo modo si insegna
ai bambini e ragazzi al rispetto per gli
animali ma anche al rispetto per
l'ambiente
tutto ciò sarebbe opportuno anche che
l'istituzione tenessero più in
considerazione comunque le associazioni
che operano il territorio perché lo
fanno in maniera volontaria e gratuita e
diciamo che in conclusione sarebbe
opportuno che la parte che mi auguro
insomma che questa questa mia conferenza
sia servita sensibilizzare le persone
che lo ascolteranno spero che di essere
stata abbastanza chiara e spero che si
sia capito la passione con cui noi
operiamo
però mi auguro anche che le istituzioni
siano più coinvolte nella soluzione di
questo problema
in particolare ci auguriamo che la
regione sardegna possa stendere i
prossimi piani regionali sulla lotta al
randagismo
considerando le associazioni che operano
nel territorio e che conoscono
perfettamente le problematiche del
territorio grazie